But if you have asked us to make a video
about the Mexican elections,
which are arguably the most important in
the history of Mexico,
but why all these elections so
important?
Well,
that's because this might be the first
time in the history of Mexico that we
say goodbye to by partisan politics,
election polls,
Lopez Obrador is 10 point nine points
above his biggest rival.
But hold on a minute here because Mexico
isn't even actually a bipartisan
country.
In fact,
Mexico has had the same political party
in governments.
Five or 70 years.
Yep.
You heard that right from 1930 until the
year 2000.
Every Mexican president belongs to the
Institutional Revolution Party.
Also known as P,
R I from their Spanish acronym and yeah,
I know what you're thinking.
How can you be a revolutionary and
institutional at the same time?
Well,
nobody really knows,
but that's the name of the party got.
Theoretically,
pri is a sense of left wing party or
they.
Many Mexicans would say that just a
casual party with no clear ideology or
identity.
The only simply their lust for power
still for 70 years,
PRI was winning.
Every election after the year,
2000 Mexicans took a 12 year hiatus from
pri with the conservative and National
Action Party,
also known as pan.
Then in 2012,
the PRI struck back and one of the
presidency with Enrique Kenya.
Yes sir.
A guy who now holds the title of
Mexico's most hated president ever,
and that is why right now with Mexico
about to hold these game changing
elections on June the first John says
that neither the Pri and all the here
and we'll win office.
The front runner is this man here,
Andres Manuel Lopez,
Obrador.
Then a worried by the Lopez Obrador
economic agenda.
This is the third time he's run for
office and it might be the final time,
Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador,
as Mexicans knew him,
and Lo has policies that,
to put it mildly scap verse out of
business people and foreign investors,
some people argue the Mexico might be on
the brink of becoming the new Venezuela
there if they choose a populist
politician like him.
Nonetheless,
his worst enemy is not businessmen.
It's actually himself.
His public statements are scaring away
all the moderate voters and that is a
problem because they could direct all of
this and um,
sentiment towards one of the other
candidate.
That's,
that's today's questions are why can
ambula win this election and all that
legitimate reasons to be scared of his
presidency feather.
We also want to look at were there any
other kinds of data could really
overshadow him in the election?
Well,
today,
good news.
We're going to answer all of those
questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the big
Mexican disappointment at the beginning
of the 21st century it seems like in
Mexico was taking no prisoners with
plenty of natural resources like oil and
Silva.
Mexico was one of the most appreciated
emerging economies in 2010.
The country's GDP growth rate of five
point five cents.
Nonetheless,
just like the other emerging economies
of Brazil and South Africa,
Mexico went from hero to zero in 2016
can GDP.
In US dollars is at its worst level
since 2010.
This is the pricing.
If we take into account that Mexico has
countless opportunities to become a
wealthy nation,
they have oil,
a good climate for agriculture and all
kinds of natural resources,
and even more importantly than those
things,
they share a border with America.
As you know,
Nafta is a trade agreement between
Mexico,
the USA and Canada,
and say 80 percent of Mexican exports go
to Uncle Sam.
Despite all of this,
Mexico is still a mid level income
country with low wages and a much lower
quality of life than it's northern
native.
You might be wondering,
well,
why is this well off to 70 years of a
basically one party system with
corruption and drug trafficking going
on?
Mexico has almost medieval institutions
and I know you're probably thinking
right now.
You're thinking,
oh,
Simon's exaggerating again.
Well,
how about you judge for yourself until
the year 2016?
That judicial system had no presumption
of innocence,
so that wasn't even a need for evidence.
In order to convict someone.
In many cases,
a confession obtained through torture
would be more than enough to send
someone to jail is fitting this academic
school.
This,
the inquisitorial judicial system added
this to the drug trafficking,
which has already killed more than
200,000 people in just 11 years
for
better understanding in some areas of
Mexico,
narcos have more power than the state
itself,
and political sciences is called a
failed state situation and this happens
in many areas of Africa and in Mexico.
In other words,
Mexica needed more than reforms.
It needed a 180 degree turn arounds for
its institutions as well.
Who was the man for this job?
Well,
of course that would be henrique a pen.
Yeah,
NASA.
That his job was to do this when he got
into office in 2012.
The problem is that it's still too early
for Mexicans to notice improvements in
their day to day lives after the
reforms.
In fact,
social unrest in Mexico,
it actually keeps growing
and you can add to that the thanks that
Kenya and yet says,
worst enemy is actually opinion yet so
himself.
Few people have worked harder to damage
that credibility basically has
everything.
One needs to become a hated politician.
Corruption scandals,
a fake phd size and lots of
embezzlement,
but this apparently wasn't enough for
him.
Do you remember Donald Trump's election
campaign and you probably do.
He was messing with Mexico every other
day.
As you can imagine,
Mexicans,
they're not big fans of trump because of
this.
Well,
Kenya is brilliant.
Idea was to invite trump for an official
visit even before he became the
president and you can probably guess
what the reaction of the Mexican people
was and then we got to consider the war
on drugs.
Festy jailed El Chapo Guzman who was the
Mexican version of Pablo Escobar.
After that,
El Chapo escaped from jail via written
all over.
It was so well built.
It was obvious.
It received help from the police.
Say to sum things up,
Kenya is the man.
People love to hate a survey in Mexico.
Pentagon,
the anthro is the Mexican president with
the worst approval rating of all time.
In other words,
Kenya and Yetta and administration
epitomizes the public's ultimate
disappointments with the Mexican ruling
class.
So Pri is not to be trusted.
Pa and is not very exciting either.
So the traditional candidates and not
really an option anymore.
So I mean,
what's left?
Well,
this is where I'm low,
comes in,
um,
low.
There was a time when emily was a member
of the PRI policy that was in the 19
seventies,
but this institutional revolutionary
party was already more institutional
than revolutionary.
Then that's why I'm.
I left them and created the party of his
own,
the Democratic Revolutionary Party,
the stronghold of the true Mexican left.
As you can imagine,
defeating the PRI was mission impossible
in Sylvia thousands that yet brought the
big crash of the biggest Mexican potty.
For one,
they lost the presidency to the
Conservatives for another,
they lost the mayor of the city of
Mexico to unload.
Becoming the leader of the biggest
metropolol all across Latin America is
not a small deal.
You get a great showcase for your
policies,
and this is why six years later,
I'm low,
almost won the presidency of the
country.
I say,
what do you do when you almost win a
national election and have become the
new left wing Rockstar?
Well,
you accused the government of election
fraud and organized lots of
demonstrations on the streets and the
let your followers name you fee,
legitimate presidents and family almost
winds this time around.
All of this could happen again.
I said in a democracy you can win and
you can lose,
but this was not a democracy.
Clearly the selection was unfair and
full of irregularities.
He does,
he of,
but now we know his history.
Let's have a look at his policies.
Basically,
Angelo wants to undo all of the made by
previous presidents.
How about some examples?
Well,
here we have the energy,
though.
Prior to this little,
all next oil was managed by these state
company.
Pemex.
This company itself suffered big losses
and we'll kinds of corruption cases and
yet and yet so and his energy bill
wanted to end this monopoly so foreign
companies could invest in the country as
a result.
Short term wise,
gasoline prices went sky high in just a
few months.
Timely wants to try and solve the
problem by giving back to the way things
were before.
The same goes for the education bill.
Prior to the current Ceville teachers'
unions held a lot of sway over public
education.
The result was lots of protests
organized by those teachers unions,
and again,
I'm low,
wants to go backwards and make those
teachers happy.
And what about drug trafficking?
Well,
Emily's plans don't stop with ending the
war on drugs,
which could be kind of reasonable.
He wants to provide amnesty for the big
drug kingpin is so called dangerous.
Criminals are mere babies compared to
the corrupt politicians,
but the best of his policies,
what we like to call his magic tricks.
For example,
how do we end corruption symbol?
We write a so called moral constitution
and remove the illegal immunity that the
members of parliaments currently enjoy.
This one is especially funny because
it's not exactly the first time that a
politician has connected those two
principles of corruption and legal
immunity and guess what?
The least corrupt countries on the
planet,
Denmark and New Zealand's have legal
immunity for them,
members of parliament.
Then again,
it does seem like a very appealing
policy for populist politicians
worldwide.
Anyway.
I'm like basically seems to have easy
and quick solutions for everything.
So the more examples,
well,
youth unemployment easy,
the government will employ thousands of
youngsters and so on and so forth with
other such examples and other words and
low and his brand new political party,
the so called marina generates a lot of
sympathy in half of Mexico society and a
lot of fear in the other half.
And this is a problem because if you
want to run for office scattering,
your enemies might galvanize them on
election day.
So the real question now is to what
extent is Amarillo willing to moderate
his agenda,
popular
or populist?
Remember this name,
Alfonso Romo.
He's a big businessman in Monterrey and
has been hazed by amyloid to become the
campaign spokesperson.
So what's his mission?
Well,
he's the man in charge of moderating
ambulance policies and making them more
palatable for independent voters.
With all the polls in his favor,
amyloid needs those votes badly.
And Alfonso Aroma is the man for the
job.
He comes from the business wells and
supported conservative candidates in the
past.
In fact,
many of emily's advisors come from
different backgrounds,
including the conservative Pan Party.
And you can really tell that they are
softening rhetoric,
right?
Remember how I told you that emily
wanted to revoke the energy bill?
Well now with phones,
say Roman was essentially said,
look guys,
it wasn't so that at the end of the day
we'll just renegotiate the contracts
with foreign companies that they can
stay in the country.
I'm low changed as mine and now he says
yes to energy,
openness according to our funds or
Oromo,
but there's still a lot more last minute
moderation.
For example,
Angela is from region,
Coles,
Tabasco here and the other is a kind of
fish cold pack.
And that's why some people live in,
nicknamed him the pain.
So now in order to give the impression
that he will not nationalized companies,
raised taxes or expropriate properties
in Venezuela and fashion,
he's launched a brand new economic
agenda called payer nomics.
No money is a big fan of risks and
experiments.
And with or without flashy names,
Mexican businessman doesn't really
trust.
I'm like,
this is why while the elections are
getting closer and closer,
this group has already found it's
canceled.
DEB's against this Mexico and like other
countries like France has no second
rounds during the presidential
elections.
That means that the candidate with the
biggest share of the voters on July the
first will become the presidents,
and this is why it seems that the
biggest antagonist to Amarillo is going
to be the conservative candidates,
Ricardo and Naya,
the Mexican business elite,
will support in order to stop Lopez
Obrador being 39 years old,
and I was the youngest candidate in this
election.
He's been accused of money laundering,
but this hasn't actually hurt him during
the campaign.
In fact,
quite the opposite is true.
People believe that this was just a
dirty trick played by the PRI to
disqualify him.
Seven dd is gaining momentum in the
polls,
although he still has a long way to go
in order to pass ambler.
So now the big question is,
do you believe amyloid will become the
next Mexican presidents and neither can
actually beat him?
Is amyloid risks to Mexico or is it hard
to do worse than previous presidents?
Well,
please leave your answer in the comment
section below and don't forget to visit
our friends from the reconsider media
podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that weren't not mine,
and don't forget we published brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday,
so don't forget to subscribe to get
those videos.
Also had that thumbs up button if you
enjoyed this one,
and as always,
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my love voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.